dude
hey chris and matt my wife's 30th
birthday is coming up and i really want
to make it big
worst wall display of all time dude
[ __ ] so high up baseball [ __ ]
diamond and a shelf too high
and a white wall go ahead hey chris and
matt my wife's 30th birthday is coming
up and i really want to make it big and
special for her yeah so please let me
know how many spin moves you think i
should do that day and
uh what else you think i should plan for
you know big surprises for her to make
sure that this is um you know her her
biggest and best birthday ever
thank you
wow good cute that you're very cool
about that
here's the thing what if he was okay
never mind not even funny what i could
recommend in terms of specifics doesn't
matter
you have to think about what she likes
dude the number one thing to do dude
okay here we go no that oh i'm agreeing
with oh good dude that's what my chicks
are always doing that [ __ ] dude it's a
deeper but they are they're like they're
like guess what
what for your birthday we're going to
creighton barrel you're like this is for
you
yeah i got your friends together and
she's inviting johnny i don't give a
[ __ ] yeah i mean i haven't had that
experience that sounds shitty though i'm
just saying though chicks love it guess
what we're doing what we're going to
[ __ ] montana you saw [ __ ]
yellowstone right right okay yeah so
deeper like saw deeper
deeper for decades
i can't really relate to that but i can
relate to this [ __ ] guy
the pressure
of what do i do for the big birthday and
he wants to make it a big deal he wants
to make her feel [ __ ] good but he
doesn't know what to do all you got to
do
is you got to be like a hunting dog you
got to be like a pi you got to sniff out
and by now i should hope there's a
[ __ ] laundry list of things that you
can think of immediately when i say this
but sniff out the things that you know
she likes and just make a list of it
like 15 20 [ __ ] things and then
whittle it down what are like two or
three of them that i can really focus on
and try to
have her experience in some way or
another on her birthday i mean this is
stupid but like does she like museums
does she like
chicks love music whatever
i love museums take her to a museum
already for real okay
take her to the [ __ ] moma oh my god
she'll [ __ ] freaking out about my museum
i did no i mean dude are you kidding me
if you take a chick to a museum you got
to bring towels i mean they're insane
they love it dude it's the most romantic
thing all you got to do is you know what
i think the artist was doing here if you
say you know what i think the artist was
doing here she will [ __ ]
[Music]
[Applause]
do the things that she likes yeah and
also dude um
like a picnic is a really good idea
you [ __ ] idiot you know
like a maybe if you take up not maybe
that's another museum idea dude if you
take a [ __ ] picnic if you take a
blanket and a basket and two sandwiches
and you just walk two or three blocks to
a [ __ ] grassy area and say sweetie
sit down for your 30th i know [ __ ] gets
crazy and you might have wanted to do
something insane but i wanted to take
some time to where it's just us and we
could have a moment for ourselves and
let you know that i love you and guess
what i'm going to love you until you're
40. and beyond but i'm saying
the decade of this decade and i love you
now take a bite of this turkey mustard
sandwich i made you that's soggy and
then do it like this where they do it
like this
and then kiss each other and [ __ ]
taste each other's mustard sandwiches
and do and do the horizontal mambo on
the [ __ ] grassy knoll
back and to the left what you just
described
is mad depressing
do you know what i mean
yeah but
again we're doing it for her she'll love
it dude and then and then while you're
doing it in the middle of it if she's
not feeling it just be like you know
what we should have done the museum huh
[Music]
[Music]
that's [ __ ] so stupid
dude
[Laughter]
so loud i mean wow you're being so loud
oh
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] dude i'm hot we're done dude
[ __ ] all right dude
hello
hello hello
[Music]